hello ladies and gentlemen and welcome
to the creek in the canyon
hell yeah at this time we actually turn
off cell phones keep people talk to a
minimum and refrain from heckling
comedians during the performance and now
i am proud to present your host for the
evening please put your hands together
for the very buddy mr holland's kingdom
what's up austin how are you guys doing
yeah lackluster good to hear
my name is pon skin we're going to have
a great dating show we're giving him to
the stage what's up samuel
what's up how are you good to see you
sexy sexy alabama man
thanks for having me the first male
guest we've had usually i have a woman
on the show so it's not too much male
energy but
look at him
sexy feminine what is this yeah can you
transition just for the show i uh
transitioned to the female now i have
now
call me samantha
you know as a male we make up 49 of the
population we are a minority so it's
about time we support minority rights on
this show with
sam kuiper
we are the 49 percent it's tough out
here for a pimp
people are looking at me worried which
means it's time to start the dating show
so how this show works is i picked two
names out of the bucket we even have one
asexual in there
uh and they go on a date live on stage
for one whole minute it might seem like
a short amount of time but it's not
and then afterwards we interview them
and ask them what they're up to who they
are and why they're uh going on dates
live on stage
so we're ready to have a good time are
you guys ready to have a good time
tonight
let's go yes
we got a lot of women signing up
some dude's gonna impregnate all these
all these women
uh last week we even had a lesbian
couple so anything is possible
the first woman coming up kelly with the
heart over the eye
all right
what do we do
[ __ ] each other
hey nice to meet you james pleasure i'm
kelly what do you do for work kelly i am
a mental health therapist oh wow yeah so
i changed lives here in austin no i live
in los angeles oh sure just visiting
about you i live in san antonio very
nice what do you do i work at a bank
okay do you like it no okay cool cool
cool
what brings you to texas just a girls
trip my girls are right over there
yeah up in austin cool yeah what about
you i live in san antonio is that far i
don't know how the distance it's like
an hour and a half okay
give or take very nice very nice yeah
yeah yeah what do you like to do for fun
play video games and smoke weed and nice
nice
i respect it
okay
um i like to drink alcohol
and watch tv
and hang out with my friends
there you go you can't go wrong there
you go
that's
for james then kelly with a heart over
the eye
nice to meet you james nice to meet you
guys james you work at a bank but you
look like babyface nelson from the uh
1920s crime syndicate it's fair i've
gotten up forbes okay you don't steal
from the bank though you're a very
honest banker
and you're a mental health professional
i am yes well hopefully you don't take a
mental health day today and uh check out
during the show uh
i will not
thank god someone's vaccinated
uh
james parsons uh what brings you to
austin texas all the way from the dirty
san antonio
my ex was doing some [ __ ] today and
i didn't have any plans so i was like
[ __ ] that [ __ ] he's a stalker
he's gonna be on the news soon
from channel four
james i notice you hold the microphone
like you're trying to be eminem you got
it
yeah are your palms sweaty
are your knees weak my arms are heavy
yeah [ __ ]
you look like you got spaghetti
look at this guy he's ready to be a
white rapper but he works at a bank so
it kind of destroys that street cred
five yeah
what uh what's the craziest thing that's
happened to you in the bank
i don't know i mean i work in the back
office mostly so it's pretty quiet so
you're like the mexican of the bank
yeah kinda i guess if you look at it
that way maybe they don't want you at
front of house
like internal investigations and [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] he makes a lot of good money
he can afford to come to austin because
his ex is doing something
something what does that mean she was
doing something yeah
joke's on you dude the thing is date
we're gonna figure this out
what's your best advice for me oh um
don't think about her she sounds like
maybe a nice lady but not great
yeah
try not to yeah i love taking dating
advice from someone who looks like she's
broken a lot of hearts
no it doesn't look like that not gonna
lie never
what's your favorite uh thirst trap that
you've posted recently
i actually posted one yesterday it was a
nice little swimsuit um everyone needs a
little self-esteem boost
shrubber but i did do that one okay
you're just wearing a halter top i was
in a swimsuit and i was doing a little a
little back dive thing and it just it
was good damn check her out on ig killah
underscore kelly
where did you say you're from l.a i live
in l.a yeah okay you know how we feel
about la people in austin yeah not
highly probably yeah
i'm from l.a too are you uh i lived
there for four months okay what's your
uh
what's your favorite part of la the
hollywood walk of stars absolutely not
absolutely not
might be the worst place there oh tell
me more
it's kind of nasty over there yeah live
in culver city much more chill relaxed
um there we go coleman good movie
theaters
yeah i mean i don't go to the movies
much but yeah i think they do have them
okay are you uh you've seen a lot of
actors in your mental health profession
you're diagnosing a lot of amber herds
birds that would be sketchy
i see a good amount of people some
people in the industry
what's the craziest just send a
screenshot of this to your ex
okay this is your work or treat
you're getting some uh spank material
for your spank bank because you work in
a bank
uh what do you think about this lovely
multi-racial couple
i don't know
i was like i'm talking to this guy
pretty good together i'm not gonna lie
thanks man
well there are two
i went on a couple you guys are they're
not gonna make it i don't think they're
gonna
i don't think they're gonna they're
gonna make it yeah he's not over he's
not over zach yeah he's not ready he's
not ready but she lives in l.a
i don't know
i'm ready it's been a year brother i'm
ready
yeah
hey
so uh
you won that were you the banker and
monopoly like what guy what got you into
banking uh there was just an open
position and he took it white privilege
right there report you were just like
you want a job sir
congratulations you went to school
what uh what school did you go to
fordham university in new york and then
i came back here for law school
law school is your lawyer you left that
part out yeah you didn't mention that
yeah well i didn't pass the bar so it's
not whatever yeah it's uh not everybody
does he didn't think
if he didn't think he could be more
unlikable he's a banker that works as a
lawyer
like a paralegal though because you
you're like a paralegal because you
didn't pass the bar
oh a lawyer banker how jewish are you
i'm not just paul not jewish at all
well
there's traffic there's trap
you know the deal what's the therapy
what's the nerdiest thing that you do
what's something that james would be
like oh i love dungeons and dragons
do you do like sudoku or anything fresh
i order hellofresh
oh [ __ ] she cooks her own food
it's got the ingredients it's got all of
it yeah recipe i do a little helpful all
right follow instructions
yeah i'm really good at following a chat
really good
that might be it
do you have a podcast that they sponsor
one episode and then i never did it
again but i do have the podcast
equipment at my house what did you give
out advice for what did you tell people
well i was the bravo therapist so i
would analyze bravo shows because i'm a
big bravo fan
one and done what is liberal housewives
all that stuff
the bravo therapist you can find me on
instagram i'll start it up again when i
get home
i'll do my episode tomorrow night walk
me through an episode what do you do you
just like
scream bravo characters from the episode
i talk about what's i mean i do it a
little bit like mental health-wise like
you know themes and stuff but mostly i
just talk a little bit of [ __ ] okay yeah
how long is each episode or how long was
your one episode like
15 minutes or so maybe less than that
actually i don't know
not too long i got to keep them engaged
you know i could talk for days though
you must be the most distracting
therapist to have
do you uh you wear do you wear that to
your uh job or
you not i do not dress more like hillary
clinton i usually just wear a sweatshirt
it's the craziest drug that you've done
i did acid in college
nice
intense
intense
you did it in college and never again
you really are a banker
i guess in san antonio they got stricter
laws
they got to police the mexicans down
there wow why was it intense what
happened
i felt exhausted afterwards i was up
from like four to six in the morning
doing banking yeah doing banking
playing monopoly by himself
it's just it was really intense
it was fun but it got dark for like a
couple hours and then
the process the whole journey i woke up
with the sunrise it was beautiful did
you like learn anything from it no not
to do it again yeah basically yeah yeah
as a therapist what do you think about
this boring ass drug trip that he took
i respect it i respect that he did it
tried it out wasn't for him but
he tried
and now he's smoking weed and now he's
smoking weed this is much more chill and
obviously had the munchies a couple
times
you're a big big man have you ever
gotten into a fight
you're a big beautiful man thank you a
bbm
apparently um bbm she thinks you're a
woman
you've transitioned in her eyes gender
fluid
anything's possible they are from l.a
but uh yeah you uh you got into a couple
fights
when i was a kid yeah
from school
that kind of [ __ ]
were you on acid when you fought someone
yeah
you were completely so how strong are
you what's the strongest thing you've
done
destroyed no i like go to the gym and
[ __ ]
he goes to the gym
i mean you're from l.a you're used to
guys going to gyms
that's not the same minutes ago it's not
an appealing hot in l.a so you're good
she's just trying to make you feel
better no
wonderful no you're a very sexy man you
have a great job you're rich you're
strong you you're a banker yeah
kelly what's the craziest date that
you've been on
oh i don't know
this
with an audience no are la guys crazier
than texas boys they're just weird
la or texas la guys are weird i don't
think i've been on any um dates with the
guys from texas until now yeah until
james now this is my best date yet i'm
happy to pop your texas cherry
settle down over there james
look at that southern charm coming from
james
i'll cover your
cover your biscuits and gravy
what uh what's the craziest uh actor
that you've dated because that is la
jade actors
athletes oh her friends know something
there is
gossip in the audience what is about
tell us about this athlete or athletes
same time or tell us about the offensive
line of the la rams
i don't know anybody from the rails i
don't think
but the chargers
other teams
just kidding okay semi-pro or probably
i'm a little older so i don't date the
pro athletes anymore you know
they're fresh out of college too young
for me you're dating uh elon musks and
billionaires now but not elon musk
he's very ugly
oh [ __ ] elon she's laying down a
challenge
could be the next uh what's that girl
grimes
yeah
yeah maybe
well uh give it up for this beautiful
couple that went on a date together
james and kelly
thank you both la in san antonio
james is showing off his strength again
watch this going off the right side
let's get another uh man and woman up we
got a couple more men signed up
shuffle him around
kelly did great
she's uh used to the big stage she's
from l.a
they look there's about santos gareth e
or
this isn't gareth bisk is it yeah it is
[ __ ] one of them
there we go
i don't like to reveal the man before
the woman but
caroline caroline
here she comes there we here
gareth has already creamed his pants
garrus and caroline give it up for them
you're on you're hot what's up thank you
thank you
take your shirt oh i'm dressed like [ __ ]
right now i'm so sorry well if you
wanted to be on stage why did you choose
that apparel uh well i didn't actually
come up today with this in mind uh
i just went out to get some food
we go on a dating show but i didn't plan
on it
that's pretty much it put your name in
the bucket that's how that's how my life
works
at least you're adventurous and
spontaneous i am very spontaneous
absolutely like to do a lot of
spontaneous things
i do a lot of firework things shows in
general fireworks yeah
you like fireworks
uh
depends on what kind oh
sweet
this is going well you guys all right
for on stage date i would say so i look
like [ __ ] she's really hot give it up
for caroline you guys
thank you
excuse how old you are i'm 28. yeah i
figured oh
here
how old are you
well a lady doesn't reveal her age oh my
time
for gareth bass and caroline
gareth fit yes
you read don't you i what you read don't
you oh yeah for sure
i do direct copywriters so i must read
yes
a creative director at a renewable
energy company that's very liberal for
someone as blonde as you are
well i'm jewish so it ladders up
hey you're looking for a whole caroline
if you're if you're looking for a good
banker i know a guy
so my mother wouldn't be happy with that
just telling me he's a lawyer banker and
that'll get her i don't need to date a
lawyer that's what all my family are
you know who is jewish though
no
i'm i'm part yeah
i'm whatever you want cameron
i'll put on a turban right now i swear
to [ __ ] god i mean that won't really
work for me but you can do it
all right if you know much about jews
but
they don't really love the turbine
americans i'll put on a yamaka too i'll
do every whatever man
what's your order of events yarmulke
turbine or turbine yamaka what did you
do i would go both honestly like why not
i just like to confuse people just
to have it all going at the same time
gareth i noticed you put the mic really
close to your mouth is that like a
subconscious homo homosexual tendency or
uh no uh i like licking nipples though
that does that's the thing yes the
famous nipples that are shaped like
microphones i don't know who you're
dating but
maybe just
at concerts
i like indian edm oh [ __ ] okay yeah you
wanna go to edm concert sometime i am
going to an idiom oh but not with gareth
that's what getting shot down looks like
everyone
that is what that looks like that
rejection was that was so that was a
very like you want to go to the game
she's like i'm already going
that's her actually
she's jewish
she's jewish she doesn't need your money
that is true
and the creative director at a renewable
energy company yes sir so what are you
creatively doing over there well if you
really want me to get into the details
yes i ever see the product department
the website
anything that has to do with
commercialization billboards so you're
getting paid by george soros
to shove
renewable energies down our coal loving
throats
yeah this is texas you should switch
it's better for you that's good energy
yeah
i work at a local vibe
oh he works in sales i work in sales and
solar sales specifically
absolutely yeah i know i'm sad
let's say bandwagon yeah
you guys are both making the world a
better place you know two jews two
liberals
what's up what's up
well i would have thought the liberals
would actually be doing something good
what what
what are you are you guys doing anything
about this like creatively marketing
renewable energy because of the gas
prices right now or like well you know
okay so that's an interesting point and
i mean like we're now we're going to get
into technicalities um there's a thing
called the tdsp which is the grid so we
can't conduct rooms in a long time but
my friends shove some
a bit of them down my throat like
because she suggested i'm vaporized
okay so i tried micro dosing and it was
fine she got drugged out of the m
a big deal i i was like
i mean my eyes are a little like
but like yeah
i mean how my eyes are now
is that how you're looking at me
yeah i'm looking at your eyes they're
very jewish
i have jewish eyes that's the first i've
ever heard of that one thank you though
i mean i just listened to your whole
spiel about renewable energies i think
we're speaking yiddish
yeah i uh i'll never ask a jew about
prices again
gareth try to keep some distance between
your mouth and the mic pretend there's a
pandemic going on i uh i'm
really trying to do that you know um i
feel though like greg abbott said
get a little further yeah here we go a
little further okay a little further
further further further further further
further that's good right there right
there yeah no tilt it too feel it
is this good shoddy
am i looking good he's about to announce
a boxing fight
yeah dude i'm ready to rumble anytime oh
anyway um yeah no i [ __ ] uh
i do a lot of mushrooms uh if you ever
want to do what drugs are you on right
now a lot of mushrooms that's true
yes absolutely i am in the gown attire
for mushrooms uh you could tilt it i am
not on any drugs at this moment but i
wish i was then you got to revoke that
shirt because that shirt says you're on
drugs
i bought it on drugs yeah that's
that's
what's your dating life like you still
dating that crazy latina chick no no
she's gone y'all can give me a round of
applause for that i'll be really nice
thank you
uh i do love latina ladies though or any
beautiful woman like he loves any ladies
that'll [ __ ] him yeah that's accurate a
hundred percent so but uh my my dating
life's pretty [ __ ] shitty though you
know oh pretty great what's wrong with
your dating life oh well uh there's not
enough of it it's usually like two or
three women
uh within a span of two or three years i
don't know
nothing like are you on the apps or what
uh no i [ __ ] hate hinge and tinder or
whatever i got really
into talking to this one chick on hinge
and then she was like you're doing so
well and then your grammar was just [ __ ]
and i was like you know what [ __ ] i can
do so much that's it that's where you
lost her i can say
you know [ __ ]
we know how much jews hate grammar
nazis exactly
tilt the [ __ ] microphone back down
dude come on
dude you're on stopping dude you can't
be sober right now
uh i mean no what
what the [ __ ] dude ratchet hey that's
just a fun person i don't know i am not
ratchet i bet you you [ __ ]
drink four locos and
no i am i'm a ranch water
where did you get a ranch
what you grew up in atlanta yeah i did
okay so you're you [ __ ] with t.i and
actually t.i is my dad's neighbor
she's rich
man
that's why he has all those unregistered
guns in his car
yeah i mean yeah he was he was in jail a
lot for those things back in the day
when i was in high school yeah yeah it's
bad to break the laws as a jew you
should know that
for sure
but uh live stream so he's gonna know
you called him a small man no [ __ ] i
mean that's fine
you heard her i'll never speak poorly of
anybody i will only say facts what's t.i
like as a neighbor oh he's actually
really nice he has good barbecues i mean
i mean he kind of gave to himself but uh
anecdotally my dad was getting married
during the pandemic and so we had to
move the ceremony to like the um i guess
it's like the communal like guest house
with the pool
and um t.i and his daughter got locked
out of their house
and during the ceremony they actually
had to go to like the guest house too
because they needed to use the bathroom
and they didn't realize it was my dad's
wedding and he was just like hey is it
cool oh my god that's fine
he's like i might come party with you
all later i'm like i doubt it but that
would be cool if you did i'm partying
with an old jewish man i'd love to see
that and that's what i told him you're
just gonna be partying with a budget
though yeah i mean this is how everyone
should talk in a microphone right
the best way to do it you you live next
to ti so you would know no i don't my
dad does i live here in austin are you
guys
stop that stop clapping stop laughing it
would be a lot nicer if we all had daddy
money let's just be real here that money
is pretty cool
it is pretty cool thank you
uh but yeah i need daddy money who's
your dad maybe i could be his daughter i
think steve i'm not going to say his
last name but he murdered a lot shout
out to steve we love you sir
one of the best news in town
uh gareth yes who's your neighbor
my passion
your party my pot dealer is my neighbor
yeah it's very convenient his name's
pancho he hangs out on the corner no
he's actually he actually has a better
job than me
that's actually
a better job yeah he has a better job
than me he actually is making plus six
figures not just selling drugs but yeah
that's my name
yeah absolutely thank you for asking
good for you what's his name and uh
address
his name's edward weeks um and his phone
number
i'm just kidding i'm not gonna want
knows edward
i'm not gonna give out his
his address right now that would be mean
edward
yeah yeah absolutely he's been a good
friend forever
caroline caroline would you do drugs
with gareth's neighbor
probably not oh probably not you're in
austin texas there's a beach i will
drink a margarita on it for sure
uh no i mean i drink ranch waters i love
a nice glass of wine i think this is
really boring though this is uh typical
austin yeah i love ranch water
outdoor bars you love bird scootering
and paddle boarding i do love paddle
boarding it's great i mean shouldn't we
all if we live here in austin gareth you
uh want to take the lovely caroline for
a little paddleboard i would love to
take you out on a paddle boarding day
cohen
i don't think you're too old at all no
you're just the right age
just the right age
garrett thinks you're 16 right now
that's right
would you be down for a paddle board
date you uh love to stand on things
sure
that's usually how it works yeah i was
going to say the same thing thank you
what kind of cheap dates are you taking
it on one paddleboard
so i've i've done a double on a paddle
board before yeah my choice
was he jewish hell yeah all right
yes yes i'm so cheap yeah hence yeah
good that's a good joke you're you're
funny we got time for
how did this uh how did this double
paddleboard date happen what were what
were the steps that led to this
well we were dating
oh so you knew him from before yeah and
you're like let's save money
let's uh let's let's be a little jewish
that's how you're supposed to do it
i thought you were a strong independent
woman i can't
catholic empathy empathic okay
well he'd be catholic gareth is honest
so he's one out of five
no almost to a fault but that's okay too
gareth what's uh something embarrassing
that you could reveal right now to
improve your honesty oh my god today i
[ __ ] my pants
today
yeah today earlier today is that why
you're wearing brown pants right now
yeah that's why i'm wearing brown you
look like a ups driver all right
yeah no just for brown dude it's just
you know vote for brown
for you yeah what for there it is yeah
exactly what brown could do for you how
did you have too much uh
yeah it was my cousin's graduation uh
last night and uh i went to her lake
house you [ __ ] your pants last night no
no no no no both the alcohol took its uh
course on me uh over the
the uh 10 hours i was asleep
from my hangover recovery and i was on
my couch and uh
yeah man i just [ __ ] in my pants i don't
know uh
i was just saying this look how straight
turned on she is by your honesty right
the honesty is really doing the trick it
is i don't have a way of owner right now
it's please
shoot a women boner yeah i don't know
what that means honestly
it's a woman all right
for all the women break down yeah break
down how women get horny to me i don't
understand
gareth get some distance yeah
look
god damn it
okay i think we're good
are we gonna give him some grace or
something i mean i'm gonna answer yes he
absolutely should have been like let's
let like let's crowdsource right now how
many people have shed their pants before
all the dudes thank you so much for
being honest
with
thank you
zero thank you
thank all of you women don't [ __ ] don't
you know this though
they don't
give it up for caroline and gareth the
thank you computer
they went on a date
i hope they're gonna go on a second one
on or near a paddleboard
and hopefully they don't need to go in
the water to [ __ ]
but uh we're gonna get another date up
here who's excited for another date
we got sydney
sydney from the woman bucket sydney
there she is she is she was uh thinking
about it and uh
for the man we got cj
gj go ahead and davis
here we go dj going one day with sydney
she hands me a life
how's it going sydney good how are you
i'm doing great i'm a little tired but
uh i'm happy to be on a date with you
where are you from i'm from here austin
where are you from i'm from las vegas
how are you visiting
nice yeah
yeah for how long about a year did you
like it
uh i like vegas
what do you what do you do
uh i'm currently
underemployed i'll say
in between yeah i'm in between how tall
are you
so
i was a i did play sports
but i wasn't like popular i don't know i
wasn't a geek though okay a little quiet
yeah a little quiet yeah this is a
little out of my comfort zone i'm not
gonna lie okay we'll get comfortable
should be comfortable we're all friends
and time get up for tj and sydney
the person that i thought was a geek did
not say he was a geek
that's the other person did
you asked him how tall he was that's a
pretty bold move so it's very important
it's like asking a woman of age to be
honest okay well i'm 24. okay well i'm
fortunate
i just let's get it for 45.
he's just been smoking 45 constantly no
i'm 36.
so uh
so what's the shortest guy that you
would date
oh
well i'm like five nine myself i'd say
like
probably five eleven six yeah
are you 511 sam yeah my tinder profile
says six foot two though
you gotta it's the builders we all make
the cut here
you got the pick of the litter and you
seem thrilled about it
uh what what do you what else do you
look for in a guy besides uh height
humor i like humor
i pretend to be funny okay yeah we could
work with it all right yeah
what's the funniest thing a guy said to
you on a date
how tall are you
yeah grace or surveillance i [ __ ] myself
yeah
that was that's a common
i actually live in henderson so whoa
two hender nights
it's been a while for me
that was 2013. you know visit
uh i would visit vegas i haven't gone to
vegas in a couple years but i would go
so you're what sports did you do so you
did sports i guess softball
volleyball
i did volleyball basketball and track
okay oh yeah i got an athlete an athlete
over here
i did this oh yeah give it up
you played basketball i guess there's
not a lot of black people in henderson
there's like seven
you gotta find them what's uh what's
your favorite thing about henderson
i don't know it is close to this trip do
you live in vegas
oh okay yeah yeah it's close this trip
it's cool i don't know it's fun i was
born and raised there so i don't know
anything different i like austin though
a real lost vegan
what is that italian restaurant in
henderson
that has olive garden olive garden no
it's so good it's so good everyone knows
it is it buca de pepo
papa john's i used to go there also cj
uh so you're from austin how do you like
all the new people moving in from las
vegas i don't appreciate it at all i
want to play austin why don't you take a
gamble on some of these uh vegas card
sharks well if are you a tourist are you
gonna move here oh no i'm just tourist
i'm with my cousins okay over here
visiting family
yeah well you know what they say in
texas cousins are not really related to
you or whatever so
yeah oh [ __ ] oh yeah south is cousins
are fair game you guys have definitely
[ __ ]
nice what's your favorite position to do
with your cousin
if anything face to face nice
anything eye contact anything with eye
contact
so uh you're from uh las vegas louisiana
you're here with your cousins my
family's from louisiana sorry okay
you're disowning louisiana right in
front of them probably a good move
right sorry
what's uh what's the craziest thing your
uh louisiana gumbo loving cousins have
done on the family reunion
at a family reunion
actually [ __ ] each other it's a joke
thanks for the clarification okay yeah i
think that we were all cute we all
bought it
yeah that's just in the movies
that's just on porno
uh cj have you ever [ __ ] your cousin
i've tried but you know it didn't work
he's tried where are your cousins from
they're all from utah so it's pretty
common out there utah
yeah we got a couple l.a you you know i
don't believe you however people get
into the relationship you're born mormon
and now you're a hormone i am a hormone
little man [ __ ] uh what's your last
date that you've been on
uh probably your show actually
okay like a real day
like where you're alone and like a real
day yeah uh
i don't know a couple months maybe five
months something like that i'm not a big
dater i like to uh you know
i got my own routines what's uh what's
something that you look for in a date
uh availability
availability with a pulse he's like yeah
anyone like four limbs a pulse you know
do you have a necklace a face
not
to keep it within the species
you uh give enough real gareth fisk
energies
uh all right i'll i'll chill out uh
scoot a little closer to the yeah
um
yeah there we go a bunch of white
rappers on stage tonight
what do you think about this beautiful
couple we got a ginger and an italian
don't get that close
we got the security bear over here
you're a jew
nice we got a lot of jews tonight that's
like plus five points it is corrupt
so now ashkenazi or what bearing
real jew i don't know he's about to
interrogate you she's a fake jew they do
well that makes sense because you're
from las vegas you know how much those
jews love money
i'm gonna keep doing these jew jokes
until one of them lands
hey uh cj what uh what ethnicity are you
i'm just like average i have done a fair
amount of math in my day so well you are
from henderson or whatever that guy is
what was that you did used to live in
henderson
yeah i don't know how do you like
henderson
she's on my app she's that has not
double up i like las vegas i like it do
you ever go what's your favorite part of
las vegas
i don't know
i show girls so i meet a lot of people
it's fun you used to work for them
yeah oh nice yeah you're a stripper yeah
hey there we go
no it's not it's not stripping yeah oh
right it's just we're not working for a
demonstration don't worry it's called
interpretive dance
he's an exotic dancer
i interpret with my [ __ ]
she doesn't do it for her cousin she's a
professional strictly no cousins
unless the money is right
i mean in las vegas that's pretty much
your mcdonald's showgirls
uh so what's the craziest thing a
customer has done on a showgirls show
um
[Music]
i don't i can't think of like a specific
i think
and he's really last friday i had a
crackhead come over and bend over and
spread his butthole nice so that that's
called gender equality man
take note
this is 2022. we gotta spread our ass
cheeks too what was he expecting when he
what was he just trying to bother like
to you he was like hey look
check this out yeah
that's a that's a work hazard how does
that happen
good
cj what do you do for work i told you i
was a little underemployed but uh las
vegas maybe he could move back to
henderson
have you ever danced for anyone sexually
uh as a matter of fact i have oh
and did you [ __ ] yourself like gareth uh
just i was no it was comfortable i had a
couple drinks in me yeah yeah
what happened how did it go down who
were these people that you danced for uh
it was only a couple times uh i used to
be married so it's kind of a you know
one of those stories
okay how long were you married uh eight
years oh wow yeah wow he really is
mormon
yes
well uh cj and
sydney thank you so much for coming up
here
two henderson natives really hitting it
off
uh
didn't get a hug oh well
next time
they're doing a little backstage
backstage
what do you think about that couple that
was uh interesting i think they're the
best chance so far
but still
a long shot
we're gonna get another random ass
couple of people here to make fun of
them we got kelly w kelly has already
been up here right
dublin okay she signed up twice she's
really horny
the thirst trap is in full effect
we got alyssa
alyssa let's go
we got a louisiana cousin coming up here
and then uh blake farrow come on up
fully thank you barrow
alyssa going to date with blake farrow
let's hope they're not cousin
hey sorry
are you are you from henderson or
louisiana no i'm from louisiana so like
edwards around louisiana yeah yeah
actually i that was too quick i didn't
mean
not too long ago yeah
what was he doing he was running on the
levee i don't you see now you're running
him no way there's no way
no he does he's actually really sweet i
can tell there's not a lot of football
fans in the audience here yeah i know
do you know what origin is anybody
there's any right now that's not from
louisiana lafayette
yeah oh i know you're from louisiana
so what do you do i'm a lawyer oh
wow where are you from i'm from fort
worth what kind of lawyer are you now
i'm uh in-house so i work for a business
okay so like can you tell me a little
bit inside like what do you do
are you defending are you good or bad
end time give it up for this lawyer and
uh louisiana bayou
lady
you said that uh your this cousin is the
hottest the one that looks like an extra
from yellowstone
so i like the guy in the parsons jersey
yeah what about uh this guy skinny post
malone or
the high asian guy
um
i cannot say i haven't [ __ ] my cousins
whoa
that's a crime here
we actually got police officers to
arrest you
uh how does how does that make you feel
blake barrow she's making some really
off-color jokes
yeah i think i've got a good chance
[Laughter]
i mean we're not blood related but
you guys look like you could be siblings
uh you tell me
i think that's a good thing for you yeah
you tell me hey blake why don't you uh
scoot a little closer get in the light
we got a little camera
i give me a mic
anchor because i have all my teeth right
look up you look good
you look good but you don't look cousin
good i'm just joking all of you have
your teeth
you look like [ __ ] you look like
everybody dad second cousin twice
removed good
you're a banker i have to ask are you
jewish
a lawyer but no i'm not a i'm not a
jewish lawyer okay
one of these days i'm going to get this
right
melissa what does your pornhub search
history look like um step
brother
first cousin
teaches
other first cousin
girl on girl
boring
every girl is into that
well you know uh you look up any gator
porn you know
i like to wrestle gators and no actually
he
wrestled a gator recently the guy from
yellowstone
nice and that got you going that's why
you're the hot cousin
was it a gator or was it a caiman
whoa
i don't know if y'all heard that he said
i commend her yeah that would
that's what he said and then
humor
that's wonderful
um yes i don't know if you're i don't
know if alyssa's goofing but
we're goofing
blake barrow uh you're from fort worth
you bank up over there with all those
poor poor mexicans
i i lawyer here with all the poor
mexicans oh okay you're an in-house
lawyer oh yeah you're an in-house lawyer
and you you were kind of vague about
what you do
well you cut me off yeah yeah i mean
well i don't want to do what caroline
does because
well yeah i'll tell you i'm just joking
okay sweet you know i just reminded this
goes out on youtube so don't get fired
that would be hilarious
i just write a lot of contracts that's
it
sounds jewish
[Laughter]
so are you rich
oh yes
there we go
from my dad yeah from my dad
he's rich
but he doesn't work in an office he
works in-house
why uh why don't you have an office
in-house okay
what are you guys talking about over
there
no i don't
yeah he works for astronauts down there
kind of boring wow
okay hopefully you were boring you got
that in common
both of you are boring you have that in
common
how many contracts are you writing
too many it's classified
nice that means i don't know what a
contract is
i'll explain to you later in the house
there we go
entertainer on the weekends what are you
doing are you uh going down to henderson
to work for the show girls or i try when
i can
entertain her on the weekend what does
that mean yeah it's in-house just for
her cousins you're a stripper on the
weekend
interpretive dancer on the weekend okay
can you show us a little interpretive
dancing about blake barrow
this date maybe tonight
oh [ __ ]
i didn't even buy you a drink yet
there we go
well thanks grant
yeah yeah that's for you now i don't
know if you know that
i don't know if you know this blake but
in uh
shut the [ __ ] up grant
you're uh really talkative
uh
i don't know if you know this but in
louisiana before you [ __ ] a woman you
have to
you know do a little dance for the
cousins before
they have to approve
it
determines everything well again it's
for all the cousins in the house
here we go
he's giving her a massage he's just
sitting on her
she is crushed
oh my god
oh jesus christ
i can see why they get for free i i can
see it
like shut the [ __ ] up
i can see why they keep you in-house
i can see why these girls are leaving
too i don't blame you at all
blame you
they're afraid you're coming for them
next
that was a great little dance that you
did like sort of a
homage to lap dance
yeah strip tease yeah yeah that's not
what i would call it but uh
it was something honestly a for effort
yeah oh wait forever you can't get that
at nasa just f for sexuality
yeah there's little nasa geeks there's
no way they could do what i just did i
know that
they could do a bad map
oh [ __ ] apparently some of our cousins
work for nasa
what uh what's up yeah are y'all jealous
i'm sorry they made me do it
yeah
yeah that'll treat yourself
what's the craziest thing that's
happened at nasa while you've been
working there that you can reveal on
youtube
boring
you just let elon musk do all the work
for you
elon musk doesn't [ __ ] with nasa
oh you're saying nasa's better than the
richest man in the world
you're saying nasa is better than uh
spacex i think opposite
oh okay you're fired now
lives here he might be in the crowd he
might give you a job
to work please elon if you're hiring
please hire me
i will take it
would you dance for the interview
process
i would yeah for him anything goes
be honest
thanks for shouting out grant
really transfers well to the podcast
uh but uh that's awesome you uh hate the
company you work for and you like
another company better
uh blake can't say things like that
because you know they keep him in house
he's a
he's a house lawyer
uh but uh great there's a lot of
lawsuits those houses sons of [ __ ]
yeah they keep you trapped up
dates do you go on
a week a month
like one a day a day a day today
obviously yeah let me look at what
this dance music
present so what's your tip it's a lie
like where do you bring a girl what are
you doing i usually bring her to a
comedy club oh and i get her and i get
on stage in front of my friends oh so is
there a girl and her cousins
right now
sam can you help me out here
nope
i picked you out of the crowd for our
next day like what are you planning what
do you want to do
they got a chance they could go to your
house with the airbnb with you and all
your cousins
cousins are out of it not the first date
this would be the second date
maybe the third
right now she's a brood after i just
danced on her
what uh when do you go back to louisiana
um tuesday
okay you gotta get
two dates in that's enough time
okay yeah yeah i was thinking that you
and me and gareth and caroline can split
two
two
yeah no caroline it's this is my date
it's your turn caroline
blake is uh
share a board
spy
somebody has to paddle blake is writing
a contract right now
still on the clock
uh
alyssa so what do you think about austin
so far you love it you love it better
than louisiana yeah i like it a lot what
uh what do you like how it smells not
like piss all the time
i'll take you a couple blocks so we can
fix that
nice oh you should go to henderson
maybe third fourth
we gotta go out of state on the third
date i thought i was in
this is a lot more work than i thought
originally in house and state
uh football fan uh blake you know you uh
look like a you look like you play
football you're in your pinstripes
already ready for jail because you hit
your wife
uh what's your what's your favorite uh
football team
uh cowboys
wow good answer i don't know why you
picked the cowboys unfortunately i was
just stuck
america's team
uh what were you guys talking about some
football player in uh louisiana
joe burrow
oh [ __ ] i thought we were boys you are
we are okay
sorry give it up for blake barrow and
alexa
the most successful day so far
well they got some good energies going
on
they're [ __ ] i think hans i'm pretty
sure i hope so here you do the woman
we got blake the
voracious
appetite he's a beautiful
talker
we got jordan coming up
what's up jordan jordan
coming on up up
the guy that's just asians
and uh chrissy vera
christie vera let's go where's she at
there we go
princessy barrel going on a date with
jordan
jordan is
uh about to come face to face with the
one and only chrissy vera out from a jog
apparently
give it up for christy vera and jordan
nice to meet you
the clock started start clock started
asia man
um new york city new york city yeah what
about you las vegas nevada same as this
one right here cool
what do you do there for fun
for fun play basketball go to the gym
hang out with friends i like doing the
typical yeah do you play basketball with
a bunch of gangsters or like classy
people yeah a lot of tattoos a lot of
backwards hats do rags okay so they're
not classy or uh no they're fun they're
super fun okay they're fun yeah i like
fun
i've never been to new york city have
you been to nevada
um yeah i went for a year do you like it
here
i'm just visiting actually on vacation
did you like it so far it's fun it's
very fun we went to sixth street the
other night was it end time give it up
for christy vera and jordan
wow
christy vero with a very classic date
question so what do you like to do for
fun
damn really low energy for someone
that's dressed athletically
i'm starving
she
got an eating disorder
so uh what what gets you excited what
gets you uh you know like
have high energy yeah are you usually
tired
i think if i saw if you have abs i get
like really definitely nothing
oh really you don't have ads i play
basketball so much i do she also likes
nipples
she does that was a joke when i said
that i liked nipples i actually hate
nobody that's the call back to a joke
that was not said on the show
apparently
do you like nipples or
abs better yeah a regular regular pair
that's actually a really nice um
i've been told
yeah
she's bragging about her nipples on a
date
way to go
that's illegal
this isn't henderson
this is texas we have very strict
judeo-christian sexual moors that we
stick to we're very repressed here i
heard it's legal in all of austin to be
tough but yeah
okay then do it
if you say so you've convinced me
get eyebrows
like you're also part liar
that's too much to remember like
goodwill hunting just korean i'm
straight 100 purebred
master race
north korean
maybe
no i'm south uh southeast southeast
korea that's how you're so tall thanks
he's not tall
yeah he is you're tall how tall are you
jordan
six feet yeah yeah uh i'm uh 511 so you
beat me there but you are part irish
okay
i'm purebred it's hard for us for korean
you're tall yeah my dick is also big for
a korean
oh really yeah four and a half baby yeah
slightly smaller than american average
uh christy have you ever been with an
asian man before i was with a small dick
guy his name okay that's not what i had
that's kind of racist oh sorry
what race was this small dictator are
you really good at um having sex and i
remember i was like wow like it's not
that bad like this is great and he goes
yep all you need is three inches and up
like so here's three inches because
that's where the g-spot is and he's
probably jewish three inches up so he
had a curve
he had a three-inch curved dick no he
just knew like how to like push up i
don't know i'm just telling you guys
well that's one of these
i don't know
liar she doesn't want to play i'm not
guy
yeah
she's talking she's talking [ __ ] about
your people jordan are you gonna defend
mutts
uh no you know what that's fine
okay
cousins
oh you guys know them you don't
held up an empty wrist
i don't think they appreciated your gift
i don't see you on any of the risks
i would appreciate it a bunch of
henderson heathens dancing the night
away what's that
nothing
uh
christy so uh what's your dating life
like are you uh currently dating what's
the last date you've been on
um
i've been around the block wow no one
admits that but thank you
yeah
um
yeah i'm on my period right now so
anything embarrassing you want to say
um
i don't know i mean like are you a
romantic type of guy or are you more to
avoid the question
sorry i say i'm romantic
you are romantic here and there
okay yeah
i believe you what's the last romantic
thing you've done
trim your eyebrows
that's probably the best i've cut my
fingernails through my eyebrows
you gotta turn the favorite thing dinner
is always a win-win you know a romantic
dinner flowers that's the way to go yeah
unless you give her some dairy
unless you got three
unless you got three inches and up
that's the most romantic thing you can
do apparently
yeah uh what's wrong with dairy yes i
know about three inches and up okay
what's wrong with that
what's wrong with dairy
you
don't you not have the enzyme to don't
you
can't eat dairy yeah and other people
can't eat it
can't eat dairy either apparently he'll
[ __ ] his pants
what a dirty little boy
can you my pounds away
is this a strip club or no it's like
there's like live music downstairs like
so you want to get in the dance you want
to wear the least amount of uh
resistance when you dance yeah if you
like if you wear the least amount of
closing clothing it shames you into like
not eating because you're like oh like
this is so embarrassing
so it shames you into like i think
you're good i don't think you need to
starve yourself
what's that why why do you why do you
think that uh
you know did someone insult you recently
or no every time i got a mental oh she
left well we had a mental health expert
here oh really every time i'm on camera
like i just look like um
this huge [ __ ] like this huge chubby
[ __ ] maybe you should stop insulting
asian people for their dicks oh sorry
maybe that's right the camera adds
10 more race racial comments yeah that's
kind of true
jordan what do you think about christy
vera do you think that uh you know your
asian parents would be proud if you took
her home i think they'd be okay with it
although i'm currently dating i think
they'd be happy with it
okay so you put your name in the bucket
to date someone you didn't but yeah with
a girlfriend would she be okay with this
we didn't say i had a girlfriend per se
oh you're currently in the dating market
you feel me right
i know i haven't felt you yet i could
feel you
yeah where should i feel
jesus christ
this is not a realistic pain will you
feel me
you gotta at least pretend you're a
normal person oh okay sorry
christy barrett is a very funny comedian
she is uh doing a bit
well i would feel his knee
energy spirit what makes you like like
you know really talkative
wow jordan is that something you could
provide for her so yeah i like cuba all
right
i like tequila i like
people with abs
um money but that's you know that's old
it's third okay she's a [ __ ]
wow sam anything you want to say about
couples
uh no
nothing no
well i feel like christy is very high
energy you're sort of chill and cool
you're like a gangster you know i feel
like it could work out she could do all
the talking you could just nod your head
yeah you could talk a lot that's fine
i'm a listener
okay
i'll talk to you about my terrible
opinions
what's a terrible opinion
um
i was just recently thinking about like
how why can't you why can't fat people
hear that they're fat why can't they
hear that can you hear fat people being
fat no like when if you say that if that
person's fat they're like whoa what
like
they can't hear it as though it's like
not a fact yeah because it drives them
crazy they start wearing spandex on
stage
right right right
i can hear like if you tell me that i'm
fat i'm like yeah i do have more of 15
more pounds but i'm not like whoa what
like no because you're not fat
it's like if you call an ugly person
ugly they're going to be more offended
than you called jordan ugly he said you
had 15 extra pounds
yeah
what are you trying to fight in the ufc
you're making weight what are you doing
um i just want to like i just want to
look good on camera
for once satisfying [ __ ] up yeah
yeah i'm a feminist
yeah there you go
yeah jordan are you a feminist
uh
uh
yes what do you know what a feminist is
jordan
jordan has to go back to las vegas he's
answering this very carefully yeah i did
yeah cause you grew up around show girls
so how could you be a feminist that's
true that's very true i mean i'm just
trying to do whatever the right answer
is
there's like playing cards for
prostitutes all over the ground where
you grew up
pokemon stripper cards
huh jordan what do you think about
abortion
bro i'm pro
he's killing babies
that's not good how many babies have you
killed jordan zero
z plan b counts i want you to know plan
b count plan b zero
nice pull out game strong i'm keeping it
if i get impregnated i'm keeping it
oh my god i respect that too do you know
how much weight you gain with the baby
oh [ __ ] yeah yeah you're gonna look so
fat on camera
yeah you could go with ali wong pregnant
amy schumer pregnant special
you also someone's yes queening you
so what do you think about jordan do you
think that he has the coolness and
suaveness to uh
wed in bed
to wet in bed
wedding and bedding well wedding is
insane right now but um
let's see what up for jordan and
christie vera
they went on a beautiful date
and that's the show
what did you get what did you think of
these this these lovely couples that we
saw tonight i thought it was great i
think uh blake might be getting laid i
don't see him out there right now oh
[ __ ] oh no she's still here sorry
blake's [ __ ] himself
blake is a bad audience member we love
alyssa on this show yeah
she was just playing him up for the show
giving him false hope
we all know that her heart is taken by
cousins
uh but uh that was a show give it up for
sam kuiper
snaps please on venmo damn
my name is hans kim thank you guys so
much for coming out and stick around for
the open mic after this show
have a good night peace
uh
[Music]
one